the Star Wars film franchise has been a
hit worldwide for a generation but it
looks like the power of the force
doesn't reach into one of the world's
most important movie markets the latest
release the last Jedi has tanked in
China and was pulled from theaters after
just two weeks Carter Evans looks at the
film's epic failure with lightsabers
fired up in the saga Luke Skywalker
continuing the force seemed unstoppable
Disney held a premiere in Shanghai but
when the film opened in China two weeks
ago the response was lukewarm you're
expecting the audience to have that
twinge of recognition and familiarity
and that just doesn't really exist in
China he doesn't exist because back when
the three original Star Wars films
stormed into theaters China was emerging
from a decade of turmoil in 1977 when a
new hope came out you know China was
still a closed country you weren't
getting the sort of massive cultural
exchange that you see now it was
literally a world away he knew the power
of the docks the stories are steeped in
mythology but Chinese movie goers have
no emotional connection to the
characters in the first week the last
Jedi earned more than 28 million dollars
but by the second weekend it was down 91
percent you didn't grow up with it then
it's just yet another fantastic sci-fi
fantasy spectacle of which there are
many
[Music]
and unless the force awakens in China
the ninth and final film due out next
year may require a Jedi mind trick to
ensure success for CBS s morning
Saturday Carter Evans Los Angeles
challenge for Hollywood now it is and
the Chinese market means a lot to
Hollywood they've staked a lot on it